we've got the function f of x is equal
to x plus 2 squared plus 1 and we've
constrained our domain that x has to be
greater than or equal to negative 2.
that's where we've defined our function
and we want to find its inverse and i'll
leave you to think about why we had to
constrain it to x being greater than or
equal to negative two why it wouldn't
have been possible to find the inverse
if we had just left it as the full
parabola i'll leave you i'll maybe i'll
make a future video about that but let's
just figure out the inverse here so like
we've said in the first video in the
introduction to inverses we're trying to
find a mapping or if you if we were to
say that y
if we were to say that y is equal to x
plus 2 squared plus 1 this is the
function you give me an x and it maps to
y we want to go the other way we want to
take give you a y and then map it to an
x so what we do is we essentially just
solve for x in terms of y so let's do
that one step at a time so the first
thing to do we could subtract 1 from
both sides of this equation
y
minus 1 is equal to
x plus 2
squared
and now to solve here you might want to
take the square root and that actually
will be the correct thing to do but it's
very important to think about whether
you're going to take the positive or the
negative square root at this step so
we've constrained our domain to x is
greater than or equal to negative 2. so
this value right here x plus 2 if x is
always greater than or equal to negative
2 x plus 2 will always be greater than
or equal to 0. so this expression right
here
this right here is positive
this is positive so we have a positive
squared so if we really want to get to
the x plus 2 and the appropriate in the
appropriate domain
we want to take the positive square root
and in the next video or the video after
that we'll show an example where you
want to take the negative square root so
we're going to take the positive square
root or just the principal root which is
just the square root sign of both sides
so you get the square root
the square root of y minus 1 is equal to
x plus 2 and one thing i should have
remembered to do is from the beginning
we have a we had a constraint on x
we had four
x is greater than or equal to negative
two but what constraint could we have on
y if you look at the graph right here x
is greater than or equal to negative two
but what's y what what what what is the
range of y values that we can get here
well if you just look at the graph y
will always be greater than or equal to
one and that just comes from the fact
that this term right here
that this term right here is always
going to be greater than or equal to 0
so the minimum value that the function
can take on is 1. so we could say for x
is greater than or equal to negative 2
and we could add
we could add that y is always going to
be greater than or equal to
1 right y is always greater than or
equal to 1. the function is always
greater than or equal to that right
there to 1.
and the reason why i want to write it at
this stage is because you know later on
we're going to swap the x's and y's so
let's just leave that there so here we
haven't explicitly solved for x and y
but we can write for
y is greater than or equal to 1. this is
going to be the domain for our inverse
so to speak and so here we'll we can
keep it 4
y is greater than or equal to 1. this y
constraint is going to matter more
because
over here the function the domain is x
but for the inverse the domain is going
to be the y value
and then let's see we have the square
root of y minus one is equal to x plus
two now we can subtract two from both
sides we get the square root of y minus
one
minus two is equal to x for
y is greater than or equal to 1.
and so we've solved for x in terms of y
or we could say f let me just write it
the other way you could say x is equal
to i'm just swapping this x is equal to
the square root of y minus 1
minus 2
for
y is greater than or equal to 1. so you
see now the way we've written it now y
is the input into the function
which is going to be the inverse of that
function x is the output x is now the
range so we could even rewrite this as f
inverse of y that's what x is
is equal to the square root of y minus 1
minus 2
for y is greater than or equal to 1. and
this is the inverse function we could
say this is our answer but many times
people want the answer in terms of x
and we know we could put anything in
here if we put an a here we could take f
inverse of a it'll become the square
root of a minus 1 minus 2 4.
well assuming a is greater than or equal
to 1 but we could put an x in here so we
can just rename the the y for x so we
could just do a renaming here so we
could just rename y for x and then we
would get
let me scroll down a little bit
we would get f
inverse of
x and i'll highlight it here just show
you we're renaming y with x you can
rename it with anything really
is equal to the square root of x minus 1
of x
minus 1
minus 2
4. we have to rename this 2. 4x
for x being greater than or equal to 1.
and so we now have our inverse function
into as a function of x and if we were
to graph it let's try our best to graph
it maybe the easiest thing to do is to
draw some points here so the smallest
value x can take on is 1. if you put a 1
here you get a 0 here so the point 1
negative 2 is on our inverse graph so 1
negative 2 is right there
and then if we go to
2 let's see 2 minus 1 is 1. this
principle root of that is 1 minus 2 so
it's negative 1. so the point 2 negative
1 is right there and let's think about
let's see if we did 5 i'm trying to take
perfect squares 5 minus 1 is 4 minus 2.
so the point 5 2 is let me make sure oh
5 minus 1 is 4 square root is 2 minus 2
is 0. so the point 5 0 is here
and so the inverse graph it's only
defined for x greater than or equal to
negative 1.
so the inverse graph is going to look
something like this it's going to look
something like
i started off well and it got messy so
let's see it's going to look something
like that just like that and just like
we saw in the first the introduction to
function inverses these are mirror
images around the line y equal x let me
let me graph y equal x y equals x
y equals x is
that line right there notice they're
mirror images around that line over here
we map the value
0 to negative to 5 right if x is 0 we
get it gets mapped to 5. here we go the
other way we're mapping five to we're
mapping five to the value zero so that's
why their mirror images were essentially
swapped the x and y